even if people may be pandemiced out as
the president says the coronavirus
continues to infect tens of thousands of
americans every day and kill
hundreds of them more than 58 000 new
cases were reported yesterday
hospitalizations are on the rise in 38
states
including wisconsin adriana diaz got
exclusive access to a hospital
in madison where the number of
coronavirus patients
doubled in the last two weeks this was
the first time it allowed cameras
inside since the pandemic began
every day nurse katie lanaway suits up
to save lives
good morning she treats patients at
university hospital in madison
where all three of their covert units
are now full
we had one hallway dedicated to covid
and the rest out here was our regular
general care
a couple weeks ago i left work and it
was that way and two days later i came
back and this entire unit became colved
are you nervous for your own safety to
be honest with you
i feel safer here around my colleagues
than i would if i had to go to the
grocery store i trust the people that
i'm working with
that they're doing the right thing
that's because outside
more and more people are getting sick to
keep up a new drive-through testing site
was just
opened at the major league baseball
stadium in milwaukee where they can test
2-thousand people per day a friend of
mine was tested positive
and i just want to make sure that i'm
safe
statewide hospitals are at 85 percent
capacity
and rising i didn't have any covert
patients a couple of weeks ago and now
my whole service is coping patients
wow dr alexandra wick says covet
patients coming in now
have more severe symptoms than those who
came in earlier in the pandemic
i had a patient the other day tell me
you know what can i do
he was so short of breath it's hard
because we're doing everything that we
can for him but he's still very very
sick
nurse lanaway wants wisconsinites to get
back to wearing masks and social
distancing
for everyone's sake patient comes in and
they
openly and willingly tell you that
they've been out at the bars
and you think about all the people that
were probably in that bar with them
and it's frustrating we don't want to
see people coming in here suffering and
struggling and we want people to be safe
and healthy so we want people to be home
the resistance to covet safety
guidelines is so strong that citizens
have sued to have them removed
a court has kept the mask mandate in
place but last week a judge blocked the
25
capacity limitations for indoor dining
until yesterday when another judge
kept those limits in place so it's hard
to keep up gail
it really is adriana but another reason
to feel grateful for the frontline
workers who are risking their lives to
save ours thank you so much